time for a little would you rather if
you were only going to play one more
year in the national football league
would you rather be Aaron Rodgers on a
team that went to the NFC Championship
game or Tom Brady on a new team but with
a bunch of weapons even though that team
hasn't had much success I I feel like I
want to say Tom Brady here I'd still
rather be on in the Tom Brady situation
you know first off there's the old
phrase of like right if you're not
getting better you're getting worse and
I feel like the Green Bay Packers that's
kind of what they did this offseason
they kind of like all we're good we went
to the NFC title game we're gonna stay
the same we're just gonna bring the team
back yeah they made a few minor
adjustments but you know listen if
you're a quarterback how could your eyes
not open up about playing with the
weapons Tom Brady's gonna have a Tampa
bet they are definitively better than
the weapons Aaron Rodgers has in Green
Bay it's not even close so I'm Brady all
the way here yeah I agree with you III
think that Aaron Rodgers would love to
switch spots with Tom Brady right now
that's the ultimate litmus test here I
mean why ask us Aaron Rodgers apply
little truth serum and/or liberal
amounts of scotch postgame scotch we
know how he likes that eventually he'd
be saying yeah I'd love to go to Tampa
Bay and be with Bruce Arians and Mike
Evans and all the weapons that they have
and the defense they seem to be hatching
and a team that feels like the arrow is
going up not at best flat in Green Bay
and like you said if you ain't getting
better you're getting worse all right if
you were a backup quarterback would you
rather be Jalen Hertz in Philadelphia
behind the often injured Carson Wentz or
Jordan Love in Green Bay behind the oft
prickly Aaron Rodgers well it's a good
question I mean it really is you know
Jalen Hertz yeah he's gonna get to play
this year in some sort of fashion some
sort of role on that Philadelphia Eagles
offense but I think ultimately if we're
talking about playing backup quarterback
I'd rather be Jordan Love
I'd rather be in his situation you know
one I don't expect we've already heard
Aaron Rodgers has reached out to Jordan
Love I don't think Aaron Rodgers
gonna be mean to Jordan love in any way
shape or form you know he's not gonna
blame him for you know the Packers
stupidity in the draft I don't think
he'll be that type of person so I'd
rather be Jordan loved one because you
get to learn behind a guy like Aaron
Rodgers sit back and just observe how he
plays the game and also I just feel like
I'd rather be Jordan love because you
know they put themselves into the corner
now I mean they this is Aaron Rodgers
replacement baby they're invested in
Jordan Love they're gonna try to make it
work by any way shape or any way they
can find possible you know this is the
heir apparent and so he's sitting there
and probably won't play much the first
year or two but either way he's the guy
that's gonna be taking the reins over
Jalen Hertz we don't know that yet
you know Jalen Hertz is a offensive
improvement he is I don't know if he's
necessarily a quarterback in the future
for the Eagles well and and the thing
about Jordan love I mean surely the
Packers can't get lucky enough to go
from Brett Favre to Aaron Rodgers to
jordan love if they don't be yeah right
right rare enough to go from one
franchise quarterback in an unbroken
chain to the next one I mean it was Joe
Montana Steve Young right that's it
that's the list Manik Manning luck
Manning luck maybe it was not unbroken
because there was that doughnut hole
year that they that they stunk enough to
get in position to get luck because
Peyton Manning was injured but I'm
talking about a continuous or another
lap between these guys we saw it with
young in Montana we saw it with Favre
and Rodgers if we see Favre Rodgers love
that will be something I think I'd
rather be Jalen Hertz this year though
because Jordan law is just not gonna
play Jalen Hertz gonna get a chance to
develop it if he plays well he'll end up
being a starting quarterback somewhere
else at some point all right one more
real quick if you're Jalen Rieger the
first round pick of the Philadelphia
Eagles would you rather have the
pressure of being picked where you were
or would you have rather gone later in
the draft but with less pressure to
perform right away I'll take you no
option number one have the pressure of
being picked where you were I mean first
off you're a first-round pick that's a
very special thing
it's an honor to be picked in the face
right but it is it's something you can
you can have on your resume for the rest
of your life to say you know wow I'm a
first-round pick it's more money yes
there's more pressure but it also means
they're gonna you know have a bigger
section of the playbook to get you the
football to so I'd rather have that
pressure being the high pick than the
later round
but we just saw yesterday when they
finalized the fifth-year options for the
first-round picks in the 2017 draft it
is a 50/50 proposition as to whether or
not a guy is going to pan out and it is
extra pressure and I also think and this
is the Michael Thomas factor there's
something that happens to a guy who goes
lower than he wanted to go in the draft
and he gets a stick in a place where
sticks don't normally go and it
motivates him and it drives him and
that's when Michael Thomas may have in
the same way if they had been a
first-round pick but it's a hell of a
lot easier to get yourself lathered up
all the time when you constantly are
walking around with that list in your
brain of all the guys who were drafted
before you that you know you're better
than Justin Jefferson who was still a
first-round pick in Minnesota has that
edge to him just because there were
three or four guys that went before him
so I think there's value in sliding
around too because it does light more of
a fire potentially but you know I I
think for me it was resolved when I had
the conversation with Joe burrow a
couple of weeks ago and I said to him
hey you know is there a part of you that
would rather not be entering the NFL as
the first pick in the draft with all the
expectations with all the pressure
wouldn't you rather kind of be
developing quietly he said huh no no
this is what you want this is what I
want and and I think the guys who truly
do rise to the occasion
they're the ones who it doesn't matter
if their pick one or pick by 56 they are
going to come to town and they are going
to be ready to play at the highest
possible level and they are not going to
fold simply because they have higher
expectations and the otherwise
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports